-The house voted today
to strip Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
of her committee assignments,
even as most Republicans
stood by her,
despite a history
of truly deranged,
bigoted statements.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Right now, as we speak,
we're in the middle
of several urgent calamities
that show no signs of slowing
anytime soon.
Poverty and child hunger
are rising.
Millions have lost
their health insurance
amid a deadly pandemic.
COVID variants are spreading.
Vaccinations are not keeping
pace with the spread.
And on top of all of that,
pilots are saying
they're making
in-flight mistakes
because they're
so out of practice.
-CNN is learning that
some commercial airline pilots,
the planes that fly all of us,
are telling federal authorities
the long layoffs
and downtime during the pandemic
has left them,
in their words, "rusty,"
causing them to even
make some in-flight mistakes.
-Pilots self-reported
being "rusty"
in at least 26 separate cases
since the start of the pandemic.
-You never want to hear the
words "rusty"
and "commercial airline pilot"
in the same sentence
unless "rusty" is the name
of a commercial airline pilot.
I mean, I would trust
a Captain Rusty with my life.
Oh, sure, sure,
there are some mornings
when he's had a rough night
and has to blow out the cobwebs
before he takes her up.
But when you lose an engine
and things go sideways,
there's no one
I'd rather have at the helm
than Captain John Rustenberger.
And the fact that you suits
at the FAA
have the nerve to question him
when your idea of turbulence
is a Lexus going over a pothole,
well, it makes me
sick to my stomach!
Anyway, where was I?
Oh, right.
Pilot is one of those jobs,
along with doctor
and crane operator
where you never want to be
"out of practice."
"Okay, folks, if you are seated
on the right side
of the aircraft,
you can look out your window
and you'll see you are looking
straight down at the ocean."
[ Laughter ]
"Also, if anyone knows
what that alarm means,
go ahead and pop on by
the, uh, pilot house?
No, that's not it.
What is it?
Oh, the cockpit.
Knew it was something crazy.
Why is it called that?
If you guys have
Gogo Internet Wi-Fi,
could you google
why we call it the cockpit?"
[ Laughter ]
"Also, do you guys pay
for Gogo all year?
I'm asking
for a talk-show host."
[ Laughter ]
We need a functional,
healthy political system
that can respond to these crises
because they're causing misery
and suffering
for millions of Americans.
And with Democrats
taking control of Congress
and the White House, there have
been some real glimmers of hope.
They're not waiting
for permission from Republicans
to do big, bold things
on everything from COVID relief
to immigration,
to the environment.
And on top of all of that,
thanks to a new
organizing resolution
finally passed after weeks
of GOP obstruction,
the Senate Budget Committee
has a new chairman
who has made clear
he has no interest
in yielding
to Republican stonewalling.
-This formalizes the reality
that the Democrats
are now the majority party
in the United States Senate.
Because we're in a 50/50 split,
we need to have an agreement
over things like
how committees would be run.
You heard from Leader Schumer
there, the deal is done.
It'll be voted on today.
That means, you know,
Bernie Sanders
is your new budget chairman.
-That's right, Bernie's
in charge of the budget now.
Get ready for direct checks,
expanded unemployment benefits,
a $15 minimum wage,
and for the Senate thermostat
to be set to 64, no matter
how cold it is outside.
"You're wasting heat.
Everyone gets a coat
and pair of mittens,
and if you're still cold,
try thinking warm thoughts.
I like to picture a kitten
sharing her yarn
with other kittens
because no kitten
should lack access to yarn."
As we've said many times
on this show,
there are massive systemic,
deeply engrained flaws
in our system
that preceded Donald Trump
and will outlast him.
He exposed them
and made them worse,
but he did not create them.
And they won't just magically
go away now that he's gone.
In fact,
he's not even really gone.
He's still exerting influence
over the Republican Party.
Just last week, he met with
house GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
at Mar-A-Lago and posted
this photo where the two of them
look like they're about to ask
if you have a structured
settlement and need cash now.
They look less
like personal injury lawyers
and more like lawyers
with personal injuries.
"Did you slip and fall
and land on your head?
Us too!
Do you need a lawyer?
So do we.
Call 1-800-1-Wait,
what's the number?
I forgot.
Hold on, start over.
Who am I?"
Also where are they?
That looks like
a Miami drug lord's pool house.
There should be a weird kid
lighting fire crackers
behind them.
Even after he's left office,
Republicans are competing
to prove their loyalty to Trump.
Take, for example, Florida
Congressman Matt Gaetz,
one of the seditionists
who spread lies
about election fraud and tried
to overthrow the results
and who looks like someone
tried to make Tom Cruise
out of Legos,
but then didn't have any Legos
so had to use Duplo bricks.
He went on
Steve Bannon's podcast,
which I assume he records
at the bottom of the sea.
Gaetz said he was so dedicated
to defending Trump
during the upcoming
impeachment trial
that he'd be willing to give up
his Congressional seat
and even his house to join the
former president's defense team.
-Would you resign in order
to defend the President
on the way
that you want to defend him?
-I love my district.
I love representing them.
But I view this cancellation
of the Trump presidency
and the Trump movement as one of
the major risks to my people,
both in my district and all
throughout this great country.
Absolutely,
if the President called me
and wanted me to go defend him
on the floor of the Senate,
that would be
the top priority in my life.
I would leave my House seat.
I would leave my home.
I would do anything I had to do.
-"My House seat,
I would leave my home.
I would burn all my clothes
and give away all my money
because that's how much
I love this man.
This man who has never returned
even an ounce
of the same loyalty
to anyone ever.
I would do anything for him.
I would live in the woods.
I would subsist on a diet
of squirrels and roughage.
I'd roam through
the forest naked
looking for fraudulent ballots
like some sort of
half man, half goblin,
scaring hikers
and feasting upon the garbage
left behind at campsites
because that's how much
this man means to me,
this man who is incapable
of human emotions
like love and compassion who,
and this is true,
once got my name wrong.
I would do anything for him."
I mean, it's just so hard
to fully articulate
how pathetic it is to be that
servile toward any politician.
I mean, do I like Joe Biden?
Sure, I mean, I guess so.
Would I quit my job
and leave my house
to go defend him
if he got impeached for --
I don't know
what he'd get impeached for.
Like, getting in a fistfight
at a bar over a jukebox?
"Hey, who turned off
'Free Fallin'?
Time for you to meet Tom Petty
and the Face-Breakers."
But there's no doubt that
this is the wing of the party
that's ascendant,
the Matt Gaetz,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Donald Trump wing of the party.
It doesn't matter if GOP
elder statesmen
want to pretend they're
part of a nobler tradition
of so-called conservatism.
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
said this week of the GOP,
"Our big tent
is not large enough
to both accommodate
conservatives and kooks."
Oh, buddy, you sound like a
middle school teacher who says,
"Listen, we can't have
a pop quiz and a pizza party.
So what's it gonna be, kids?
Okay, I'm not hearing
a lot of 'pop quiz.'"
Actually, your tent
is big enough for both.
Yesterday, House Republicans
voted to retain Liz Cheney
in her leadership position and
gave Greene a standing ovation.
Your tent is big enough
for conservatives and kooks
because it's a circus tent
or one of those large
outdoor wedding tents
where you get speeches
from kindly grandpas
telling cute stories
about the bride
and drunk aunts
who steal the mic
and refuse to give it up.
"When I first saw
these two together,
I knew there was a spark,
kind of like the spark
caused by the Jewish space laser
that started the wildfire.
No! No, Pamela,
I will not sit down!
This is my time!
I'm being canceled!"
I'd tell Liz Cheney
to just leave the GOP,
but being a Cheney, I doubt
she has an exit strategy.
Iraq War joke.
[ Laughter ]
God, it's nice
now that Trump is gone
and I can get back
to doing my Cheney material.
It's a real shot in the face.
[ Laughter ]
Now, it's worth stepping back
and remembering
that these people are massively
unpopular with normal people.
Trump was, according to polling,
the most disliked president
in modern history.
He never cracked 50%,
lost the popular vote twice,
got impeached twice,
lost the House
by a record margin in 2018
then lost the Senate,
not to mention he oversaw
the worst public-health crisis
and economic crash in 100 years.
Meanwhile, every single
executive order Joe Biden
has issued so far that's been
the subject of polling
has either majority
or plurality support,
and even a majority
of Republicans
support the $1,400 checks.
If we had an actual democracy
with a level playing field,
Republicans would wield power
as often as the Jets
make the playoffs.
They'd tank every year
but then win just enough games
to lose out
on the top draft pick
and get stuck with some
second-tier quarterback
from one of those super specific
part of the state schools
you've never been to,
like Southwest Idaho Tech
or Northeastern Montana A&M,
a guy with an unforgettable name
like Matt Jones or Jake Smith
or just Steve.
"I don't like this Steve guy!"
In a normal democracy,
the Republican Party
would be forced to dump all
these deeply unpopular goblins
because they would have to
appeal to a majority of voters.
But we don't have
a normal democracy.
We have a system where the GOP
has won the popular vote
one time in the last 32 years
and where the 50 Senate
Republicans represent
40 million fewer Americans
than the 50 Senate Democrats.
So Republicans have no incentive
to appeal to most Americans,
only to their base, and their
base is increasingly unhinged.
New polls show that Republican
voters favor Greene and McCarthy
over Cheney and McConnell,
despite the fact that Greene
has said, among other things,
that school shootings were faked
and that Nancy Pelosi
should be executed for treason,
questioned whether a plane
crashed into the Pentagon
on 9/11, and suggested
that a Jewish space laser
caused wildfires.
I know we keep mentioning
the space laser,
and it does sound insane
out of context.
But it's worth actually
reading what she said.
This is what Greene wrote
in a 2018 Facebook post,
when, to be fair,
she was only in her early 40s.
Anytime someone says there are
too many coincidences to ignore
and their name isn't Fox Mulder,
that's your cue
to exit the conversation.
It's like wandering over
to someone and hearing,
"Look, I'm not saying dolphins
definitely are secret agents
trained by the CIA to spy on us.
I'm just asking why are they
always jumping out of the water?
What's so interesting up here
that they just
have to look at it?
Why are they always smiling like
someone just told them a secret?
Also, the way they click,
that's Jewish Morse code.
Oh, got to go.
Time for my wedding toast.
Don't side-eye me, Pamela!"
And yet despite her history
of expressing support
for political violence
as well as anti-Muslim
and anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories,
yesterday, McCarthy
basically stood by Greene
and claimed she'd apologized.
-I denounced all of those
comments that were brought up.
Everybody --
And she came to the --
She came inside our conference
and denounced them, as well.
She said she was wrong.
She has reached out
in other ways and forms.
She has expressed
that she has put it out
from news agencies and others,
I think it would be helpful
if you could hear exactly
what she told all of us.
Denouncing Q-on.
I don't know if I say it right.
I don't even know what it is.
Any from the shootings,
she said she knew nothing
about lasers
or all of the different things
that have been brought up
about her.
-Okay. First of all, you don't
know how to pronounce QAnon?
Isn't that exactly
what a Deep State
Satanic cult member would say?
Sorry. There are just too many
coincidences to ignore.
Second,
you should probably learn
since a lot of your voters
are super into it.
That's like Kid Rock saying,
"I'm sorry.
How do you pronounce this?
Ba wit daba?"
Second, if you want us
to hear her say it,
then why doesn't
she just say it?
If she's so sincere
about her apology,
then why doesn't
she make it public?
Is it a secret?
Is this like when you forget
to buy your wife
an anniversary gift
and you tell her you have one
but you can't show it to her yet
because it's too good
and she needs
to mentally prepare for it,
and then you spend
the rest of the night typing
"things my wife likes"
into Amazon until Amazon types
back, "I'm not her husband!"?
She obviously is not sincere.
She's been raising money off it.
And then, today she spoke
on the House floor,
where instead
of apologizing unequivocally
and denouncing
her previous comments,
the best she could do was this.
-I also want to tell you
9/11 absolutely happened.
-Oh, my God, thank you.
It is so big of you
to admit that.
What else would you
like to clarify?
"I would also like to make clear
that 'Inception'
is just a movie,
RoboCop is not real, and the
giant glowing orb in the sky
is in fact the Moon
and not a secret sky bank
where Bill Gates
keeps all his gold bars."
Then she went back to saying
more heinous stuff
like equating the media
with QAnon.
-Will we allow the media,
that is just as guilty as QAnon,
of presenting
truth and lies to divide us?
-Are you insane?
Wait. I'm sorry.
Why am I asking this
as a question?
You are insane.
"The media and QAnon
are both guilty
of dividing Americans
by claiming a secret cabal of
baby-eating Satan worshippers
is running the government.
Wolf Blitzer,
I accept your apology,
if that is your real name.
I see you under that beard,
space laser."
Nicely done
on the graphic there.
I had no idea what
it was gonna look like.
Kind of a fun little payoff.
The Republican Party
is radicalizing
against democracy and away
from the political mainstream
because it has no incentive
to appeal
to a majority of Americans.
That's why we need far-reaching
structural reforms
to our democracy
to level the playing field.
A system where one party
can yield power
despite representing
40 million fewer Americans
in the Senate and winning
the presidential popular vote
once in 32 years is not tenable.
Because right now,
we have one party
that's based in reality
and another that believes in --
-Lasers.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV-AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.